we had heard about a virus one of us had
heard about it we'd supported each other
and it ended up since the positive and
at that time they said 25% of people
seem to only be getting sick with this
virus so do what you do live your life
healthy be good come back and see us
again in a while which shows that the
lifestyle of some male homosexuals has
triggered an epidemic of a rare form of
cancer I went back come out 9 months
later and they said that only 25% of
people were surviving meaning that
everyone was dying which later evolved
the next year into 100 percent of people
were dying there was nobody that was
surviving the virus the conditions
severely weakens the body's ability to
fight disease researchers are now
studying blood and other samples from
the victims trying to learn what is
causing the disease so far they have had
no luck hi I'm Keith and I've been HIV
positive since 1985 so I'm one of those
one of those survivors I'm leaning up
against the building where I'm about to
go in and get a sculpture treatment the
sculptor something I've done several
times over the years which is help with
facial wasting which is a result of
medications from HIV I'm dr. Robert
Cohen today we're working at being alive
which is a hiv/aids social service
agency we've set up a program called the
facial reconstruction program earlier
medications that were used to treat HIV
an age caused fat loss they would cause
fat lipoatrophy or lipodystrophy which
manifests itself as a hollowness
primarily in the mid-face area in the
temples down low people get that as they
get older but with the HIV patient
population it was a more acute and it's
a more severe form of facial wasting
you know you're living with a virus
inside you a lot of your friends die
you've survived this thing and then it
starts to appear on your face it starts
to show and all of a sudden you're
looking in the mirror and you're seeing
the actual disease itself at the time I
was acting in modeling my agent I
remember he called me he said you just
got a call from a casting director who
wanted to know like what's up with Keith
he's not looking like usually looks
is he sick is something going on and
that kind of started the end of like
really the end of my career what we've
done we put white cream and it's a
numbing cream the numbing cream takes
about 10-15 minutes to work it will numb
up topically I need to get the product
into his face so for the first couple of
injections it helps make it more
comfortable for the patient it became
kind of a terminal death sentence
automatically and there's no medications
for it there's nothing to treat it and
your own government has turned its back
on you because it made it a gay disease
it just sucked because we're having to
prove that we were a value to live in
the first place and the doctor said no
cures and there was no leads on anything
and people were just dying left and
right you were choosing which you knew
you had to go to on the weekend because
you had to make a priority of which
person was more important to you this
product is called Sculptra it's what's
called the biologic filler it's a
chemical that will stimulate the body's
natural production of collagen we're
going to inject the patients in the area
that he or she needs and the patient
will wait for about a month and they'll
start to see the collagen grow in their
face will be the volume loss will be
replaced with collagen it lasts about
one to two years I wasn't able to get a
job I was having these symptoms it came
to being alive literally just put my
arms out stretch them straight out and I
just started sobbing and I said
somebody's got to help me and that's all
I said they just put their arms around
me on both sides and just took me into
the back just basically just helping me
with whatever I needed in and one of
those ended up being Sculptra well thank
you for coming and joining us and
letting me stick sharp objects in your
face and always drinks my driver HIV is
now what's called a chronic maintenance
disease the patients now will continue
to live a long and healthy life along in
print
ducked of life it is a disease and it
can change your life there's always hope
whether it's HIV whether it's diabetes
whether it's depression there's hope
take your medication talk to your
doctors and most importantly surround
yourself with people whether they have
the same disease entity or something
else and reach your hand out and help
them nothing feels better than helping
somebody else and that's what we're here
for
we're on the boat together let's help
each other Road
[Music]
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part